why is it so hard to be on time like why
does five to ten always become 20 to 30
if my dad is on fleek am i lit why is it
a problem if I like anime why do black
people look at your shoes before they
greet you why are we more likely to
engage in the new dance trend and then
we already get involved in politics
we're opening a business how did
watermelon become our thing like
everybody should love watermelon why do
you get upset what I don't like black
celebrity race aside some people are
just terrible what do we call each other
the n-word but get vehemently upset when
a white person uses the n-word it drains
my soul to hear the word and I just
don't understand how people who have any
understanding of history can use that
word why is my natural hair the hair
that grows out of my head seen as a
political statement we think people with
white skin look better than people with
dark skin do you really believe that
black is beautiful or is that just
something you say cuz it sounds cool why
do you sound like we will say that
you're pretty for a dark-skinned girl
when that is said to me it still makes
me feel like the ugliest little black
thing why do some black men only date
white women why is it okay for black men
to date white women but not OK for a
black woman to date outside her race
why do you protest black lives matter
and then tear each other down to the
next breath why do we say that we don't
want to be seen as a monolith but then
try to take people's black cards away
for not liking something that's
supposedly black why are we so quick to
support a non black owned business but
then hesitate when it's a black owned
business I mean is there a cut-off time
for this whole homophobia thing in the
black community because I'm really
looking forward to that while I was
growing up without a father so common in
our race why don't we like to confront
our mental health issues therapy is such
a wonderful and magical place why is
there a checklist for being black why is
being educated considered a white thing
why can't I love school and also be
black why do I have to be mixed in order
to have long hair why do you think
well-off black people don't know what it
means to be black black isn't only
defined by adversity why do some black
people say oh I have Native American and
my family in order to feel interesting
or more
than other black people around them why
can't we just acknowledge that there are
a bunch of different types of black
people walking around and they're all
amazing and unique and special in their
own way we within the black community
are so quick to kind of tear each other
down and to look towards other races in
terms of their success and in terms of
what they have but never want to kind of
look into the mirror ourselves I love
black folks but that doesn't mean I
don't have questions why are we always
looking for the discount shoot angle
obligate discount - Donnie - I'm one of
them